la prison de poissy sera t-elle déplacer
une consultation citoyenne numérique va
être lancée le samedi 1er juin par la
mairie pour connaître l'avis des
habitants une décision qui fait écho à
l'effondrement survenu le 28 mars
dernier d'une partie du mur d'enceinte
de la prison notre prison est édifié ici
depuis 18 ans 21 ça fait presque 200 ans
je ne parle même pas auparavant avec le
couvent des ursulines dans les années
750 elle a l'âge de ses artères et elle
est de plus en plus dangereuse pour les
administrés ne sont pas à l'abri d'un
mur qui s'écroule
nous souhaitons aller plus loin et je
souhaite consulter les pisciacais pour
savoir si comme nous ils souhaitent ou
non le maintien de la maison centrale en
centre-ville pour donner leur avis les
habitants de la commune devront
télécharger une application sur leur
smartphone ou leur tablette
le dispositif sera également accessible
dans les maisons de quartier le vote
sera quant à lui anonyme est unique on y
aura trois réponses possibles
oui non ou votre blanc et nous avons
fait appel à un organisme sécurisé
proposé par notre part entre partenaires
orange pour pouvoir rassembler
l'ensemble des vols en toute
confidentialité clic une personne qui
puisse voter à la fois évidemment les
résultats seront dévoilés le dimanche 7
juin à partir de 11 heures en mairie
sont transmis au ministère de la justice
gestionnaire de la prison il est évident
que si les pisciacais et les pisciacais
aller dans le sens d'un nom maintient
donc d'un transfert de la prison
ailleurs que dans centre ville ça ne
donnerait plus de poids et je pourrais
dire de pression mais plus de poids plus
d'arguments encore pour valider ce que
nous souhaitons depuis des années c'est
impossible
selon l'élu le déplacement de la prison
sur un autre secteur de la ville
coûterait près de 80 millions d'euros
contre 60 millions pour une rénovation
promise par l'état pour la remplacer
différents projets sont à l'étude comme
un musée ou des espaces verts